9h du matin pièce d'eau des suisses à
versailles 550 courageux équipé d'une
combinaison ont pris le départ du
triathlon du roi dans une eau à 17
degrés cette épreuve phare regrouper des
licenciés masculins venu se tester sur
la distance là on est sur une distance
est-ce donc ils viennent de faire 750 m
de natation
ils sont actuellement sur 20 km de vélo
et ensuite ils enchaîneront sur 5 km de
course à pied disputée jusqu'au bout sur
le vélo ou à pied la course s'est jouée
dans le sprint final après une heure
cinq minutes et 8 secondes
brice gayant ancien pensionnaire de
versailles est aujourd'hui à issy
triathlon remporte l'édition 2019 je
mets vraiment m'imposer charest qui
avait des gros clients
donc je me suis pas retournée à vélo
j'ai été tout seul quaade s'est passé on
est sorti à trois de l'eau après ils ont
eu un peu de mal à la transition donc
j'ai eu dix mètres j'en ai profité
comme mon point fort c'est le vélo
peu après appelé bages tout donner quand
les autres cours ont terminé beaucoup
plus loin mais avec le sourire une bonne
course on a bien roulé il faut que tu es
un parc ouvert donc tendue avec c'est
parfait la nage toujours un peu
compliqué sur le plan d'eau de
versailles le vélo bien les ont fermé un
peu dans un groupe e qu'ils voulaient
pas rouler que course à pied on essaye
de donner ce qu'on peut quoi mériter
tous les participants se retrouveront
l'année prochaine les organisateurs du
versailles triathlon festival ont déjà
annoncé vouloir organiser une onzième
édition